the recent floods in Pakistan claimed
more than 1500 lives and the government
estimates losses of around 30 billion
dollars the food supply has also been
endangered after wide swathes of
agriculture land were affected wheat is
planted mainly in Punjab but wheat
fields are also found in the province of
Sindh which was heavily affected by the
floods
the trains aren't running anymore after
the flats damaged infrastructure here
it's devastating not just for travelers
but also for the many Porters who work
the Line stations have been jobless
since the rain submerged large parts of
Pakistan
how will I pay rent somehow I saved my
family from the flood brought them from
my Village to Karachi thinking I would
earn money and support my family but I
haven't been able to earn anything
because trains aren't running
[Music]
the deadly floods submerged a third of
Pakistan
farmers in affected regions don't know
how they will feed their livestock
This Grass has rotted because of the
floods it has turned black it can't be
fed to the livestock that means that the
animals will starve and die as a result
around 700 000 head of clado drowned
during the floods alone according to
official estimates the livelihood of
many here wiped out it's a catastrophe
many are trying to sell their surviving
livestock at the market but no one is
buying because there's no feed or the
little there is now too expensive
we have been destroyed by the floods
our animals are dying
no one is buying them we're helpless we
appeal to the government to buy these
animals from us we have nothing to eat
how are we going to feed our animals
people are desperate the effects of the
disaster will be felt for years Pakistan
not only needs billions to rebuild it
also needs hope
my colleague Warda Imran joins me now
speaking of Hope Warda what more can you
tell us about the destruction of the
Harvest and how it's impacting the lives
of pakistanis is their hope
well I think that's a tricky question of
course there is hope but I think more
than that there's also a very big sense
of loss and Devastation people have lost
their homes they've lost the way they
make income they've lost their
livelihood a lot of people in rural
areas have difficulties even accessing
shelters where it's not uh you know
totally drained out or whatever as you
said the estimated loss is over 30
billion dollars and prices that were
already skyroding skyrocketing prior to
the floods have now gone up four five
fold even further for tomatoes and
onions that are like that are so
necessary for for just households for
dinner and lunch and inflation and
stability political instability has made
it even more difficult and so I I
definitely do think that there is hope
but I think a lot of work needs to be
done to rebuild it
so a Confluence of factors there but I
wanted to zoom in on the agricultural
industry what has the catastrophe meant
for Pakistan's agricultural industry
well so Pakistan is mainly driven by
agriculture so a lot of the times you
know how you assess how an economy is
doing you assess that with with
agriculture with Pakistan wheat is our
main stable crop and agriculture is over
19 of the GDP and employs almost 40
percent of Labor so as you can tell
that's really important sector and a
little change even and this is huge but
even a little change can have
devastating impacts on the way people
move and so when agriculture is impacted
it's the economy is going to have a hit
now ahead of these floods there were
already worries about Pakistan's
financial situation some were even
saying it might be the next Sri Lanka
how is the government coping with the
situation that's now gotten even worse
well I think that's that's the biggest
question is how will we deal with this
once we go for it there's a bigger
payment coming in in December I think
it's an international bonds and uh well
analysts and experts on ground predict
that funding bodies like the IMF will
step in when they obviously do so they
come with their own kind of parameters
of policy change and there's always
internal Rift on how to react to these
um but it seems that the growth aim that
the government aimed for I think earlier
was touching three percent but now it's
it's a bit of a more sad Outlook where
it says this maybe even two percent
would be difficult but I think um in
terms of Aid or relief there has been a
lot of positive outlook from countries
in the region and funding bodies that
are actually
um trying really hard to assist Pakistan
in this way so let's hope that it gets
better then thank you Warda Imran there
talking about the economic toll of the
Pakistan floods